I'll do we know the word actually is a
lot of things but we're talking about
the hardware itself and Arduino is a
microcontroller surrounded by a bunch of
other components that that controller
needs to function and then Arduino more
broadly is the sort of ecosystem and the
software in the community and all the
things that go into making it what it
isn't and has become so popular we're
going to do a sort of guided tour of the
Arduino Uno board which is the board
that most people are going to start with
the Arduino it's the simplest I guess in
that it it hasn't got any extra Kroft
that a lot of the more advanced boards
have but it has some features on it that
make it easier for a user that the
really tiny cheaper as we know it's
don't it's the one that you get in a lot
of this the starter kits when you buy
like a kit with not doing it with
resistors and capacitors and things
probably tend to come with you know the
heart of it is this chip here this is a
at mill at the Atmel of the company you
actually manufacture the chip that the
part number is 80 mega three to eight P
so that's the device that your code runs
on and it's a fairly standard
microcontroller and well the odd wheeler
board does is bring the pins that
microcontroller out to these edge
connectors so that you can use those
pins and your software in your projects
so we've got analog inputs one of the
features of this microcontroller is that
it can read analog voltages between 0
and 5 volts turn it into a number in
your code that you can then do mass with
amount of temperature sensor that where
voltage output is relative temperature
you can turn it into a number do some
math and getting the actual temperature
out and they turn a fan on or turn the
heater on or something like that but on
this side we've got the digital inputs
and outputs so perhaps that's more
familiar that's just opinions either on
or off 1 or 0 some of the pins have got
this little tilde wavy line symbol that
means they can output in the Arduino
it's called analog right that's not
actually strictly speaking analog it
doesn't vary continuously between 0 and
5 volts it just has sort of the same
same effect it's called pulse width
modulation and maybe that's topic for
another video and then got some power
pins and there's a research so you can
reset the program
from a remote sources if you want to and
then iof is a sort of reference voltage
for the analogue input so it needs to
know a base level to correctly convert
the voltages on these pins into numbers
most of the time I think iof is just
left alone certainly for most beginner
projects I don't think anyone touches
iof this top left section the board here
here's a power input so when you're
programming your Arduino you're doing it
through the USB and that also provides
power when you've actually finished and
it's done in your project you don't want
to have to leave it connected to a
computer all the time so you can plug in
7 to 12 volts into this connector here
just a normal power supply there's a
chip here called a regulator that turns
your voltage input into the 5 volts that
the Atmel chip needs and then the rest
of this it is or support components of
the powers of capacitors to perform
smoothing you've got a diode there to
protect you from wiring and power the
wrong way around
silver device in the middle here is the
oscillator the clock for the chip so
just like your desktop with a laptop you
need a clock the one your desktop or
laptop will run in the gigahertz range
of speeds this is 16 megahertz so it's
put your slope a comparison one of the
things that's made Arduino so popular
and so ubiquitous and obvious well is
that they put a USB connection on it
normally microcontrollers of this kind
you need a special bit of programming
hardware which cost money and then your
computer needs the drivers to talk to
that especially with programming kit
that you plug into this header here it's
called ICSP
in circuits oogle programming that's a
load of fact that users beginners don't
have to go through so I'll do a no said
white we're going to we're going to
program it with the USB that adds extra
expense maybe because this chip itself
knows nothing about USB it hasn't got
any USB Hardware on it USB is quite a
complicated protocol to implement you
need quite a lot of software and
hardware embedded in the chip to do that
so this chip being relatively cheap and
simple doesn't have that on just talks
normal optical serial data so what they
did is put this interface chip here this
chip talks USB
to your computer and translates that
into cereal to talk to the Atmel chip
there as far as computers concerns
talking to USB device over cereal as far
as the Arduino is concerned it's talking
cereal this is a bit of an aside the
early versions of Arduino used a
dedicated USB to serial converter chip
and then at some point Arduino went over
to a using another microcontroller so
this chip here just like this is a mug
from usual design right so is this one
it's there purely for the purpose of
doing a USB to serial conversion or
serial to USB conversion and I suspect
on a Arduino did that because they
wanted to put extra features into their
communications to the Arduino that they
couldn't do with a standard serial chip
mainly for programming so one of the
things you have to do in Arduino when
you're programming is in the other new
IDE is go and select which Arduino is
plugged in you want to select serial
port and then also as a separate
operation select whether it's an you
know or duemilanove a or the Nano or
whatever chip is the latest latest
version validly already tries to auto
configure it for you so if you select
the arduino that's on comm port 9 it
says oh i know that's a nano and you
don't have to go through that exercise
because that computer that causes a lot
of confusion for people because they
think they're compiling the code for a
particular Arduino mega filing for
another and things start going wrong
you've got three LEDs so TX and rx are
the serial communication that we just
talked about so they flash when the
Arduino is transmitting or receiving and
then this one it's labeled L I don't
know why that is it's attached to pin 13
so all of these digital pins nothing is
attached to them so you're free to
interface what if you like to them P 13
is special it has that LED on and that's
many so you always got something on the
board that you can see is working so if
you think it's all going wrong and you
don't sure what's happening you can go
back to basics writer a programmer
sketch that just blinks the LED on pin
13 at least if that works then you know
you haven't killed the chip there's
nothing wrong with the power that kind
of thing that's good for test purposes
yeah yeah and finally I'll write in this
top corner there's also a reset button
so you can
most people here so you cannot raise a
reset your program it can be useful if
your programs got really locked up it's
going horribly wrong and you want to
reprogram it or just wipe it entirely
sometimes it helps before programming if
you hit reset that gives the USB and
seal all the chance to kick this chip
into programming mode so you can
actually reprogram it
we usually pin 13 so we tell it 13 comma
outputs this should turn blue which it
does and we close the brackets and puts
em come